dr. Eliza and greyer had once been a
slave she went on to become the first
african-american woman licensed to
practice medicine in the state of
Georgia after emancipation
Eliza crier decided to become a teacher
studying for seven years at Fisk
University in Nashville Tennessee but
she aspired to a career as a physician
believing she could be of most benefit
to others and earn a fair wage if she
had a medical education when I saw
colored women doing all the work in
cases of a Koosh menthe or childbirth
and all the fee going to some white
doctor who merely looked on I asked
myself why should I not get the fee
myself so in December of 1890 Eliza
crier wrote to the woman's medical
college of Pennsylvania I have no money
and no source from which to get it she
wrote only as I work for every dollar
she asked the Dean if there was any
possible way for an emancipated slave to
receive any help into so lofty a
profession she was admitted but to pay
the tuition
Eliza crier alternated each year of
study with a year of picking cotton
despite these hardships she did not lose
sight of her goal after seven years of
work and study she graduated in 1897 and
returned to Atlanta
later that year dr. Eliza and Greer
became the first African American woman
licensed to practice medicine in the
state of Georgia after only four years
dr. Greer fell ill and was unable to
maintain her medical practice determined
to keep up with her work she called on
various supporters for help
she wrote to susan b anthony leader of
the National American Woman Suffrage
Association to ask for her help but died
soon thereafter as she said in 1898 I
went to Philadelphia studied medicine
hard procured my degree and have come
back to Atlanta where I have lived all
my life to practice my profession some
of the best white doctors in the city
have welcomed me and say that they will
give me an even chance in the profession
that is all I ask
the North American Medical Review
reported she will hang out her shingle
for general practice and says she will
make no discrimination on
of color dr. Eliza crier realized a
remarkable achievement